I just want to show the world those
shoes please show those shoes off
[Applause]
explain the process of those shoes the
shoes I mean it's just Chanel man I got
to give it to them it's everything on
here you know everything the ribbon the
earrings the whole nine yards is Chanel
and you look spectacular
don't forget about the gentlemen okay
finish you look good too much I
appreciate it and let's see hold it
there we go
Billie are you singing the Bond theme
tonight tonight no I'm not no I'm not
I've seen more um come on you're doing
the in memoriam it's in a more iam it's
it's not about me this is about them you
know showing love fact beautiful oh it
really is true cuz I don't want it to be
about me I want people to be watching
the screen watching the people and you
know very listen it's a great thing to
do but it's a very difficult thing to do
is for sure for sure yesterday on my
home Brian I'm really looking forward to
like
what's the word I guess respectful and
respecting all the people that have
passed this year yeah that's all I'm
here to do I know they've added
something special for Colby can you tell
us anything or how did you how did that
affect your planning I mean it's just
it's like it's I don't know what else to
say like makes your heart cut every time
every because when we were in rehearsal
and they run kind of what's going to be
playing it's like every time I see his
face I'm like what like it's so weird
right you don't it doesn't make sense to
me keep playing it's just I just
if you can have the best time ever
tonight which I
[Music]